START A CALL THIS MEETING TO
ORDER.
I WELCOME ALL MEMBERS THAT ARE
HERE WITH US TODAY AND OF COURSE
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE FOR
TODAY'S JEDI HEARING.
I LIKE TO FIRST I RECOGNIZE THAT
WE HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT
SECRETARY IF YOU PLEASE CAN CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
CERVANTES YOUR CHOOSE A POINT IS
HEREBY SIR CUNNINGHAM.
CHAO [inaudible]
GEN.
GEN HERE RAMOS.
RAMOS HERE COOLEY.
COOLEY HERE SMITH.
SMITH HERE SENATOR WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
THANK YOU AND I WILL START JUST
STAR SINCE WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
AUTHORS OUR ANNOUNCED SO WHAT WE
HAVE ON FILE TODAY WE HAVE FIVE
BILLS ON FILE.
ONE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB THREE OH
TWO IS PROPOSED CONSENT BY
PORTANTINO.
ARE RELATING TO AN ARMENIA TRADE
OFFICE ARE THERE IS A LIST OF
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION THAT IS OUT TO EACH
MEMBERS.
I JUST AS WELL AS OUTSIDE OF
TODAY'S HEARING ROOM.
AND THE LAST ANNOUNCEMENT THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE IS -- TODAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY WILL BE
REPLACING ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
THE ITEMS THAT WE DO HAVE ON
FILE OR ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
FIVE FIVE EIGHT WEST SO ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB SEVEN THREE
EIGHT WATCHED SO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB.
FIVE EIGHT EIGHT ARCHULETA.
AND ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SEVEN
THREE SIX AMBERG [inaudible]
OF I BELIEVE WE HAVE AN AUTHOR.
AND THEN.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR ONE HOW ARE
YOU WONDERFUL.
HOPE I'M NOT LATE.
RIGHT ON TIME FOR THEIR
ANNOUNCEMENTS THAT I UNDERSTAND
WE HAVE TO BILLS OF YOURS THAT
TODAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGAN
WITH SB FIVE FIVE BATES YES
THANK YOU AND MY MY BOTH MY
BILLS.
I SHARE A COMMON THEME IN THAT
THEME IS -- OF BENEFITING FROM.
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
BIGGEST TRADING PARTNER AND ONE
OF OUR CLOSEST POLITICAL ALLIES
AND A NEED OUR NEIGHBORING
COUNTRY.
IS -- REPRESENTS THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA BORDER WITH MEXICO.
AND WE HAVE FOUND THAT AND
ANYWHERE WE PLACE -- IN ECONOMIC
AND NEVER ALONG THE BORDER.
THAT'S ONE INVESTMENT THAT.
TURNS OUT TO PAY.
ENORMOUS DIVIDENDS FOR OUR
ECONOMY AND FOR THE OUR
COMMUNITY SO.
I HAVE DEDICATED MYSELF TO
WORKING TORTILLA FURTHER THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO OF FOR
THE PURPOSES OF EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PEOPLE OF
OUR STATE.
WORKING TO REDUCE FOR WORK WAIT
TIMES BECAUSE THEY HELP -- TO
DRIVE ECONOMIC INVESTMENT SO --
WE'RE WORKING ON THESE BILLS.
LONGORIA. TO FURTHER THAT CAUSE.
I SB -- FIVE FIVE EIGHT FIRST OF
ALL IF I COULD MENTION ON SB
FIVE FIVE IT WOULD LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING ALL THE AMENDMENTS.
AND I WANT TO THANK FOR STAFF
STAFF.
HAS.
ALWAYS DONE A GREAT JOB WORKING
ME APPRECIATE ALL THE YEARS OF
OF SERVICE TO TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND I APPRECIATE THE THE
RELATIONSHIP WE'VE WE'VE CREATED
AND AND ALL THE BILLS THAT WE'VE --
SOUGHT TO ADVANCE THAT HELP TO
CREATE -- ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE.
CALIFORNIA SHARES OVER A HUNDRED
AND FORTY MILES OF OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER WHICH IS.
ALL MY SENATE DISTRICT WITH
MEXICO AND AS WE'VE SEEN AS
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IS IMPROVED
WERE NOW THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY.
MEXICO'S ECONOMY HAS ALSO
IMPROVE THEIR NOW THE FIFTEENTH
LARGEST ECONOMY.
WORKING TOGETHER WITH WITH
MEXICO CAN PAY ENORMOUS
DIVIDENDS TO THE PEOPLE OUR
STATE ESPECIALLY SINCE WE HAVE A
POPULATION.
THAT SHARE SOME CULTURAL TIES
SOME LANGUAGE TYPES AND AND WHEN
WE HAVE PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
THAT HAVE.
SOME LEVEL OF ACCU MEN IN
BUSINESS.
AND BRING WITH THEM SO A
CULTURAL HERITAGE THAT IS
CLOSELY LINKED WITH MEXICO.
WE NEED TO BENEFIT FROM THAT
OPPORTUNITY -- TO BRING MORE
JOBS AND AND PROSPERITY TO OUR
STATE.
SO -- THIS BILL [inaudible]
AND WOULD.
WOOD -- CREATE THE COMMISSION OF
CALIFORNIA.
MEXICO AFFAIRS THIS --
COMMISSION WOULD BE A CITIZENS
COMMISSION THAT WOULD BE TASKED
WITH -- CREATING TIES FOR FOURTH
FURTHERING CAUSES.
AND IT CAN HELP US ACTIVATE A
FULL SET OF BENEFITS THAT COME
WITH A STRONG CALIFORNIA MEXICO
PARTNERSHIP AND THAT IS --
REACHING OUT -- TO IMPORTANT
AREAS OF PUBLIC POLICY --
REACHING OUT -- WITH -- WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO THE SOUTH IN IN A
CREATIVE PUBLIC POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
CAN ADOPT.
IT CAN BE A WHOLE SET OF
CREATING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
MEXICO [inaudible]
AND OF AGAIN -- I WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE. TWENTY SIX POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN TRADE WITH
MEXICO SUPPORTING.
FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
JOBS KNOWING THAT THERE'S
ENORMOUS ROOM TO IMPROVE THAT.
TO INCREASE THAT AND BRING MORE
PROSPERITY TO THE PEOPLE OF OUR
STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE FOR THIS BILL
TODAY AND I HAVE -- LANCE SO
SPEAKERS HERE IN IN IN SUPPORT.
WHAT THE CHAIRS AGAIN WHEN
YOU'RE?
YES GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME IS
OUR MONDO BASKING ALMOST ON THE
PROFESSOR AT CAL STATE LONG
BEACH SHOW WAS THE FOUNDER OF
THE KIND OF THING STUDIES
DEPARTMENT -- FIFTY YEARS AGO.
AND I'M ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL BECAUSE I AM -- EARLY
HONORED TO PROVIDE HIS TESTIMONY.
IT SEEMS THAT IT'S ABOUT TIME
THAT WE STOP ASSEMBLY IN THERE
WILL BE MORE LONG TERM.
SO WITH HIS COMMENTS -- THAT I
PREPARE FOR YOU THIS MORNING --
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
COMMISSION CALIFORNIA MEXICO FOR
YOURSELF -- AS WIZARDING
MENTIONED -- BYE BYE SENATOR
WESSEL -- IT'S TO ADDRESS THESE
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO THAT
COVERS A HUNDRED FORTY MILES OF
MY SON BORDERS.
BUT I'M NOT ROLE I'M I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEXICO STUDY CENTER -- ON CAMPUS --
WE HAVE THE IN.
A RUN AS A CALIFORNIA MEXICO
PROJECT AND NOW FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AND WE HAVE SERVE AS AN
EDUCATIONAL CULTURAL
ORGANIZATION -- WHOSE MISSION IS
TO RESEARCH TO DEVELOP.
FROM MORNING STATUS POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS WITH THE HIGHER RATED.
AND CULTURAL ORGANIZATIONS -- TO
ENHANCE THE TEACHING THE
MOBILITY OF STUDENTS AND FACULTY.
AND PROFESSIONALS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA MEXICO -- AND ALSO
WITH.
THE THE US AND MEXICO -- I AM
CURRENTLY -- RUNNING A PROGRAM
THAT WE STOP RELEASED -- SOME
FIVE YEARS AGO TO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES IN.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS AS THE
MODEL THAT IS PAID BY THE
DISTRICTS -- ON SATURDAYS WE ARE
TEACHING THAT CLASS IS WITH
COLLEGE CREDIT.
BUT THE RELEVANCE OF THAT IS
THAT IN MEXICO THERE IS VERY
LITTLE THAT IS KNOWN ABOUT THE
LOVE YOU MEXICAN ORIGIN
POPULATION SO -- WE ARE PLANNING
TO COME THROUGH THE SCENE IN
OCTOBER TO CELEBRATE THE
ANNIVERSARY OF UP TO TEN OF YOUR
STUDIES.
BUT ALSO TO BEGIN TO RESEARCH
WHAT THAT RELATIONSHIP IS ABOUT --
I THINK THAT UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE OF THE THE CONTIENEN GET
THE RHETORIC ABOUT BUILDING
WALLS.
AND SHUTTING DOWN THE US MEXICAN
BORDER IS JEOPARDIZING THE
FUTURE OF OUR STATE'S ECONOMY.
AND THE IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIP
WITH A FORMER SEE CAN ONLY ONE
WHICH IS IS MEXICO -- IN MY
OPINION CALIFORNIA MY SACK TO
PROTECT THE ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP
WITH MEXICO AS WELL AS THE
SECURITY HEALTH SAFETY AND WELL
BEING.
OF THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA -- BY
ESTABLISHING THE STATE
COMMISSION FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA
MEXICO AFFAIRS WE CAN BE SURE OF
THE CALIFORNIA THAT CALIFORNIA
WOULD PROTECT THE INTEREST IT'S
PEOPLE.
BUY PREMIUM MEANS TO PLAN AND
DISCUSS THE MUTUAL CHALLENGES
AND OPPORTUNITIES RELATED TO OUR
CHAIR BORDER.
AT THE END OF FUTURE
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO AND
PROMOTE POLICIES AND JOIN
PROGRAMS THAT ENHANCE IMAGE OF
PROSPERITY FOR WE GO INTO ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
OUR WITNESSES I WANT.
TO ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
OBJECTIONS TO ADOPTED ADOPTING
THE AMENDMENTS BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT FRIDAY OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SO WE CAN GO AHEAD AND MOVE.
FORWARD WITH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL.
BUDGET ARM ON BEHALF OF THE IN
CARROLL COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS RIVERA MUCH
APPRECIATE THE SENATORS
COMMITMENT TO THIS.
I THINK YEARS FROM US ALL THE
TIME ABOUT THE CHALLENGES FACED --
HE HE VERY MUCH KNOWS THAT ON
THE BORDER -- IT'S DIFFERENT
THAN ANY OTHER LOCATION
CALIFORNIA I MEAN WE'RE
BORDERING OTHER SOVEREIGN NATION
AND OTHER STATE IN THE CASE OF
IMPERIAL COUNTY AND THAT BRINGS
WITH IT CHALLENGES FOR SO WE'VE
OFTEN FOUNDER SUCCESSES ARE BEST
WHEN THEY'RE DEALT WITH THAT THE
CITIZENS LEVELS WE APPRECIATE
SORT OF THE CITIZENS.
COMMISSION PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
BECAUSE OF THE THE STAKEHOLDERS
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE AND WORK.
MARK THERE SO I APPRECIATE THE
BILL AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO ANY OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH IN THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS
I'M I JUST WANT TO CLOSE BY --
DEEP THINKING THE AUTHOR FOR
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS I AM WORKING WITH OUR
STAFF ON THEM I THINK MANY OF US
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
AND BUILD A STRONG PARTNERSHIP --
AS RELATES TO FOREIGN TRADE AND
ECONOMIC -- JUST INVESTMENTS --
WITH MEXICO AND THE U. ALL
RAISED VERY VALID POINTS ON ON
THE RELATIONSHIP AND THE
STRENGTH THAT BETWEEN THE TWO SO
I APPRECIATE THAT THIS BILL AS
WE SEE IT MOVE FORWARD AND IT
HAS OUR FULL STE MY FULL SUPPORT
TODAY.
SECRETARY IF YOU CAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ITEM TO SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT THE
MOTION IS DO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR
CERVANTES AYE CHAU CERVANTES ON
FOSTER CUNNINGHAM.
CHAU CHEN.
CHEN I RAMOS.
RAMOS A COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE SMITH [inaudible]
SMITH I NOT VOTERS FIVE ZERO AND
IT IS I DO PASSED WITH THE
MOMENTS YOUR PREPARATIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THE VERY MUCH MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR YOU HAVE BUT SENATE BILL
SEVEN THREE EIGHT YES AND SEVEN
THREE EIGHT IS THE COMPANION
MEASURE TO THIS.
AND THIS ALSO -- THE THAT SEVEN
THREE WOULD ESTABLISH INITIATIVE
FOR CALIFORNIANS ARE BROUGHT IN
MEXICO AND ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS.
AND AND SIMPLY -- TALKING ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING A
PHYSICAL LOCATION IN MEXICO AND
WORKING TOWARD.
ESTABLISH A A PLACE WHERE
CALIFORNIANS CAN FEEL AT HOME
ALL IN MEXICO BUT AS A RESOURCE.
FOR THEIR ENDEAVORS IN IT ANY
AREAS RELATED TO EDUCATION --
BUSINESS AND AND CULTURAL
DEVELOPMENT WHERE WERE --
PROMOTING AND AND OUR STATE OUR
PEOPLE.
AND HELP IN -- ARE --
CALIFORNIANS SUCCEED WILDER
MEXICO.
THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ON THE SECOND
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH -- ON
THE BILL HI YOU'VE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU ARE JUST SIMPLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AND APPRECIATE ALL YOUR SUPPORT
PASSED THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
ANY WITNESSES YES.
AGAIN LET ME REMEMBER QUICKLY
WHEN I PREPARED -- I'M NOT ONLY
HONOR SPEAK INTO THE MIKE SO --
I'M LITERALLY HONORED -- I'M
VERY HAPPY THAT THIS --
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN INTRODUCED
BY SENATOR WESSEL BECAUSE AS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE HAD A LACK OF A
PRESENCE IN MEXICO FOR ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS -- AND THIS
CERTAINLY OFFERS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TO REACH STAB RELEASE THAT
OPERATION ANY PARTICULAR COMING
FROM THE CSU SYSTEM -- I'M
REALLY PLEASED THAT THIS WILL
ALLOW FOR THIS YEAR'S YOU OF THE
COMING INTO COLLEGES AS WELL AS
THE UC. TO ALSO BE PART OF THIS
IN THIS PARTNERSHIP -- AS YOU
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
HAS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD.
AND THIS IS POSITION OUR STATE
AS A GLOBAL LEADER BUT TO A
LARGE EXTENT THIS HAS BEEN DUE
TO THE RELATIONSHIP WITH WHEN
MEXICO.
AS OUR TOP ECONOMIC PARTNER AND
NOW I HAD THE THIRTEEN LARGEST
ECONOMY BUT YOU SAID FIFTEEN SO
WHO KNOWS TO IT DEPENDS ON ON
WHAT THE WHAT THE WEEK.
MAKES IT JUST.
LAST MONTH BUT WHEN YOU'RE THE
FACT IS THAT BOTH ECONOMIES
COMBINED CONFORM THE MOST.
PRODUCTIVE REGION IN THE WORLD
WHEN YOU COMBINE THOSE TWO
ECONOMIES YET WE DON'T HAVE LONG
TERM PLANS POLICIES AND
COLLABORATION.
WITH THE PENDING RATIFICATION OF
THE US MEXICAN AGREEMENT -- NOW
BEFORE CONGRESS AND THE MERGING
YOU FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION ON
THEIR PRESENT LOW PERSONA NOR.
THIS UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY
THAT ALLOWS FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
CULTIVATE A MORE PRODUCTIVE
COLLABORATION WITH MEXICO AND
DEVELOP LONG TERM POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS.
AND TO FIND NEW AND INNOVATIVE
WAYS TO ME DOMESTICALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY -- I WANTED TO
POINT OUT SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN KIND OF OFF THE
RADAR.
I HAVE A PERSONAL CONCERN THAT
WE HAVE BEEN TRACKING NOW FOR
THE LAST.
OF FIVE SIX YEARS IN FACT THE
FORMER SENATOR LOU LOU QUREIA.
ADDRESS THE SOME -- DIRECTLY
WITH THE FOR ME AMBASSADOR OF US
AMBASSADOR MEXICO IN THAT'S THE
PROBLEM ARE YOU A CITIZEN
CHILDREN.
THAT HAVE BEING FORCED INTO A
FORM OF EXILE IN MEXICO WITH
THEIR DEPORTED PARENTS.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THE NOBODY HAS
REALLY PAID ATTENTION TO AND I
THINK THIS IS THE KIND OF
SITUATION THAT -- COMMISSION
CERTAINLY THIS OFFICE YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO.
IN THERE FOR ME PROVIDES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A POLICY AGENDA.
IN THE AS WELL AS THE THE ISSUES
OF PRODUCTIVITY AND THE ECONOMIC
COMPETITIVE SO WHAT THE
COMPETITIVENESS OF BOTH MEXICAN
THE U. S. -- WE ARE SUPPORTING
THIS LEGISLATION BECAUSE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE INITIATIVE.
FOR CALIFORNIA SO BROWN WITH
JENNER IN ON PARA LONG TERM
ECONOMIC POLICY PLANNING PROCESS.
TO SECURE THE FUTURE OF OUR
STATES ECONOMIC RELATIONSHIP
WITH MEXICO AND AGAIN A
CONGRATULATING THE GOOD THE
LEADERSHIP OF OR SENATOR BEN
HUESO FORTY CAN THE SONG.
BECAUSE IS DEFINITELY BEGINS TO
SHAPE A LONG TERM AGENDA.
THANK YOU IN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OTHER ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I TYLER I YOU ARMY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT WE ARE THRILLED ABOUT
THE IDEA OF HOSTING -- THIS --
THIS INITIATIVE AT ONE OF OUR
CAMPUSES EXCUSE ME IN MEXICO
CITY SO I JUST WANT TO SAY WE
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR.
AND HIS STAFF -- FOR TAKING UP
THIS ISSUE AND I WOULD
OPPOSITION BUT VERY SUPPORTER OF
THE IDEA THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
FIVE SEE NAINA WILL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE
DO HAVE A FIRST AND THE SECOND --
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CNN I
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR ACCEPTING
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ARE THERE ANY OBJECT
AND OBJECTIONS TO ADOPTING DOT
BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
I SECRETARY IF YOU CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THIS BILL IS DUE
PASSED WITH THE MEMONS TO
PREPARATIONS.
ITEM THREE SB SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR
CERVANTES AYE CHAU CERVANTES ANA
PLACER CUNNINGHAM.
CHAU CHEN.
CHEN HI RAMOS.
MOST ON A COOLEY.
COOLEY ON A SMITH.
SMITH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL LEAVE
THAT THE ON CALL.
WE HAVE THE ITEM NUMBER FOR
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
SB -- FIVE EIGHT EIGHT GOOD
MORNING PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOUR
RIGHT -- ARE WE READY YES OKAY
GOOD.
GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN.
AND ESPECIALLY TO YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
ENTER YOUR MEMBERS I WILL BE
TAKING COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE ED THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THEIR DILIGENT WORK.
ON SB.
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW AND ARE VERY WELL AWARE THE
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED TO SUPPORT DISABLED
VETERANS SEEKING.
TO SEEKING REHABILITATION AND
TRAINING THROUGH.
THEIR PARTICIPAION AND BY
LEVERAGING THE STATE'S MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL CONTRACTS.
SO THE VETERAN CAN PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROGRAM.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND NINETEEN
FOLLOWING AUDITS OF THE PROGRAM
THE STATE ORDER.
REPORTED THAT MANY CONTRACTS
AWARDING DEPARTMENTS ARE DOING A
DISSERVICE TO VETERANS IN
ACQUIRING AND MAINTAINING
CERTIFICATIONS -- TO VETERANS
WHO ARE CALLED SUBCONTRACTOR AND
PAYMENTS MADE TO THEM.
DISABLED VETERAN CONTRACTORS
HAVE BEEN MY OFFICE THAT THEY
ARE BEING MIS USE MISREPRESENTED.
AND UNDER PAID IT IN SOME CASES
THAT THEY'RE EVEN LISTED ON
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS BIDS.
BY PRIME CONTRACTORS WITHOUT
BEING PROPERLY NOTIFIED OF THEIR
PARTICIPATION AND RESPONSIBILITY
IN THE BED ULTIMATELY THE
CONTRACT.
FURTHERMORE THEIR NAMES ARE
BEING USED TIME AND TIME AGAIN
IN DIFFERENT BIDS FOR DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS CONTRACT
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT.
AND WE MUST FIND THIS APPALLING
WELL EXISTING LAW PROVIDES
SERIOUS PENALTIES FOR PRIME
CONTRACTORS WHO KNOWINGLY
PROVIDE FALSE INFORMATION TO AN
AWARDING DEPARTMENT REGARDING
THIS PAYMENTS TO SUBCONTRACTORS.
THERE IS NO CORRESPONDING
PENALTY FOR PRIME CONTRACTORS
SIMPLY FAILING TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION AT ALL.
WE MUST PROVIDE THE MEANS THE
CLOSEST THAT A LOOPHOLE SO WE
CAN ANALYZE THE PROGRAM PROPERLY.
SB FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT WILL
PROTECT DISABLED VETERANS --
WITH THE FOLLOWING ENFORCEMENT
TOOLS.
EXPAND THE ELEMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUSLY MANDATED
CERTIFICATION BY THE PRIME
CONTRACTORS TO INCLUDE.
THE FOLLOWING THE PROJECT NAME
ASSOCIATED WITH EACH DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS AND SUB
CONTRACTOR AND THAT ALL PAYMENTS
SPECIFIED IN THE SUB CONTRACT.
HAVE BEEN MADE TO THE DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS.
WHEN A PRIME CONTRACTOR FAILS TO
REPORT A SUBCONTRACTOR PAYMENTS
THERE WARDING DEPARTMENT SHOULD
BE REQUIRED TO NOTIFY THE
CONTRACTOR FIRM AND GIVE THE
RESPONSIBLE TIME?
AND BE GIVEN RESPONSIBLE TIME TO
REPORT THE DATA. FOR THE
CONTRACTOR THAT FAILS TO RESPOND
WITHIN A REASONABLE TIME A TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS CIVIL PENALTY
IS SET FOR A FIRST VIOLATION.
FOR SUBSEQUENT VIOLATIONS AND
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES INCREASED
BY TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH
TIME. FOR EXAMPLE THE SECOND
FENCE WOULD BE TWENTY THOUSAND
AND THE NEXT THIRTY THOUSAND AND
SO ON BECAUSE REMEMBER THESE ARE
LARGE LARGE CORPORATIONS WITH
BILLION DOLLAR MILLION DOLLAR
CONTRACTS.
SO THE SMALL VETERAN THE
SUBCONTRACTOR IS THE ONE WHO'S
TRULY AFFECTED.
THIS REMEDIAL PROCESS AN
APPLICATION OF CIVIL PENALTY
SUNSET -- WILL SUNSET ON JANUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE REQUIRED
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S TO
ANNA AND BEFORE JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE COMPLETA
COPPER TO HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
AND ASSESSMENT OF THE PROGRAM.
SO YES IT'S SET SETS AND TWENTY
FIVE BUT IT TWENTY THREE WILL
TAKE A GOOD HARD LOOK.
AT WERE WHAT PROGRESS WE'VE MADE.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WILL
ALSO REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES TO CONTRACT THE
ANTI CONTACTED DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE WHEN A PRIME
CONTRACTOR REQUEST TO SUBSTITUTE
THE VETERAN SUBCONTRACTOR IN THE
ORIGINAL CONTRACT.
SO WHEN THESE VETERANS HAVE
THESE ARE NAMED AS A
SUBCONTRACTOR AND THERE REMOVED
THEIR TO BE PROPERLY NOTIFIED OF
THE REMOVAL AND WHY.
THE SB.
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT IS SUPPORTED
BY SEVERAL VETERANS
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE PROGRAM
ITSELF.
IN A HAD RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ARE THERE ANY CRITICISM SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND STAFF MY NAME IS AFFECT
VARGAS WERE AND FOR THE UNITED
STATES VETERANS BUSINESS
ALLIANCE WE ARE THESE SPONSORS
AND SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL --
THIS IMPORTANT PROGRESS --
PROGRAM IT IT WAS REALLY CREATED
AND SPEARHEADED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND OUR ALLIANCE
WHICH COUNT SEVERAL -- HUNDRED
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESSES AND
OWNED BUSINESSES AS WELL AS
VETERAN ON BUSINESSES -- WE'RE
TRYING TO SPEAR HAD SIMILAR
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE NATION
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT -- WE
DON'T HAVE TWEAKS AND CHANGES TO
BE MADE TO THIS PROGRAMWHICH
WE'RE DOING THROUGH THIS BILL
WE'RE PROUD TO HAVE WORKED WITH
THE OPPOSITION -- THEY'VE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION IS THE
SANDERS -- HIS HE SAID BEST
WALKING US THROUGH THE BILL AND
WE'RE WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LAMAR HAS TAKEN WITH
ASIAN INCORPORATED WHERE A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
ORGANIZATION BASED IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE'RE PROUD. FOR
THE COMMITTEES AND THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE EXPANSION PROGRAM
WHICH WE'VE BEEN IMPLEMENTING --
WITH GOBIZ -- OUR ORGANIZATION
STATES -- ITS SUPPORT FOR THE
DVB PROGRAM BUT ALSO FOR
IMPROVEMENTS THAT DO NOT
MARGINALIZE AND IN FACT RAISE UP
THE CHANCES THAT DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISES CAN
RECEIVE CONTRACTS WE'VE SEEN IN
OUR EXPERIENCE TO MY COLLEAGUE
TONY TANG WITH OUR SAN JOSE
MINORITY BUSINESS CENTER CAN
ATTEST.
MANY OF OUR DVB EASE -- RECEIVE.
YOU KNOW OPPORTUNITIES OR
PROPERTIES THE BID AND BE PART
OF A A PROJECT BUT THEN THEY
DON'T END UP WITH THE WORK SO
WHATEVER CAN BE DONE SUPPORT --
DVDS TRULY HAVING THEIR FAIR
SHARE OF THE WORK AND NOT JUST
LISTED AND BEING TOKENIZED AS
PART OF A BID.
WE SUPPORT AND WE THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS CONSIDERATION
OF THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE HOURS BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH IN THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
I THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- I WILL ASK.
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY IF
THERE'S UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ADOPT THESE AMENDMENTS WONDERFUL.
SECRETARY FOR COMPLETES CALL THE
ROLL WE HAVE A DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH MAN.
THANK YOU.
I AM FOR SB FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR CERVANTES.
CHAU CERVANTES I'VE OYSTER
CUNNINGHAM.
CHAO.
CHANNEL I CHEN.
CHEN I RAMOS.
RAMOS A COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE SMITH [inaudible]
SMITH I THAT IS SIX ZERO WE WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON WE
HAVE ONE MORE ITEM ON FILE WE
WILL.
ALL THE SENATOR.
SO WE CAN GO AHEAD AND TAKE A
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR SB
THREE OH TWO I FILE ITEM ONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS DUE PASSED WITH THE
MOMENT SURE PREPARATIONS.
ON CONSENT EITHER ONE SB THREE
ZERO TWO PORTANTINO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMEND CONSENT.
CHAIR CERVANTES.
CHAU CERVANTES ON FOSTER
CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHAO ON IT CHEN.
CHEN HI RAMOS.
RAMOS HI COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE SMITH [inaudible]
SMITH I I'D LIKE TO LIFT THE
CALL ON THE FOLLOWING ITEMS FILE
ITEM TO SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT WEST
SO FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON ITEM TO
SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT TO MOTIONS TO
PASS WITH THE MEMBERS TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
BUSTER CUNNINGHAM CHAO
[inaudible]
CHANNEL ON FILE ITEM THREE SB.
SEVEN THREE EIGHT ITEM THREE SB
SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THE MOTIONS
TO PASS WITH MEMBERS TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FASTER CUNNINGHAM.
CHAU [inaudible]
CHANNEL ON AND PLEASE LOOK AT
THE KHAN ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB.
FIVE EIGHT EIGHT I AM FOR SB
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS WITH MEMBERS TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
BY SIR CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
SO I WILL ANNOUNCE ARE ON
CONSENT ITEM NUMBER.
ONE NOT THE BILL HAS SIX ZERO IN
IS OUT DO PASS WITH THE MOMENTS
TO PREPARATIONS.
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
FIVE FIVE EIGHT WITH THE SIX
ZERO VOTE NOT BILLS OUT TO DO
PASSED WITH THE MEMONS TO
PREPARATIONS.
I DON'T NUMBER THREE SB.
SEVEN THREE EIGHT WITH A VOTE OF
SIX ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WITH A
DO PASS WITH THE MEMONS TO
PREPARATIONS.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB.
FIVE EIGHT EIGHT WITH A VOTE OF
SIX ZERO THAT BILLS OUT WITH THE
D. PASSED HIM WITH THE MOMENTS
HERE PREPARATIONS
.
JUST SO MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE
ARE WHERE WE ARE CURRENTLY
WAITING. FOR THIS -- SENATOR
UMBERG HE'S CURRENTLY PRESENTING
IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE WHICH IS
RIGHT ACROSS THE HALL SO SHOULD
BE JUST A FEW MOMENTS BEFORE.
WE WILL TAKE UP THE LAST ITEM ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY THANK YOU
PLEASE GO THROUGH THE BILL'S
SIDE THAT ARE OUT SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE A VICE CHAIR SYMBOL MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM.
AT ON ON CONSENT ITEM ONE SB
THREE ZERO TWO PORTANTINO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMEND
CONSENT.
VICE CHAIR CUNNINGHAM.
FRAZIER CUNNINGHAM ON ITEM TO SB
FIVE FIVE EIGHT TO MOTIONS TO
PASS WITH MEMBERS TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PRESSURE CUNNINGHAM.%
VESTER CUNNINGHAM I ITEM THREE
SB SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WITH MEMBERS TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BY SIR CUNNINGHAM.
FASTER CUNNINGHAM I ITEM FOR SB
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS.
TO PASS WITH MEMBERS TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SPICER CUNNINGHAM.
BY SIR CUNNINGHAM BY.
I JUST FOR A CHECK [inaudible]
ALMOST ALL
[inaudible]
WELCOME SENATOR.
WE HAVE AN EFFICIENT COMMITTEE.
THIS.
IS BUT WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB.
SEVEN THREE SIX I REMAINING ON
TODAY'S AGENDA I SENATOR PLEASE
BEGAN WHEN YOU ARE READY HI NO
RUSH -- THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- BEFORE YOU HAVE
SB -- SEVEN THIRTY SIX CREATIVE
ECONOMY INCENTIVE FUND -- THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA
GENERATED FOUR HUNDRED SIX SEES
ME FOREIGN SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN ECONOMIC OUTPUT ACROSS THE
STATE.
ACCOUNT FOR ONE POINT.
SIX MILLION DIRECTED INDIRECT
AND INDUCE JOBS IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIXTEEN ALONE.
HOW ARE THE APPROACHES FOR
ATTRACTING SIGNIFICANT EVENTS
HAVE PROVEN TO BE -- A VARIETY
OF APPROACHES FOR TRACKING
SIGNIFICANT EVENTS HAVE PROVEN
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN RECENT YEARS.
AND ARE BEGINNING TO PULL OTHER
EVENTS INTO THE STATE.
OF THESE EVENTS INCLUDE --
CULTURAL ACTIVITIES RODEOS THE
ALL ALL ALL SORTS OF ARTISTIC
EVENTS.
OTHER STATES FOR EXAMPLE --
LOUISIANA HAS A MAJOR EVENTS
INCENTIVE PROGRAM WHICH IS BEEN
USED TO ATTRACT SPORTING EVENTS
SUCH AS THE SUPERBOWL NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP.
GAMES -- WITH THIS IN MIND SB
SEVEN THIRTY SIX CREATES AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM WITHIN GO BIZ.
TO UPON FUTURE APPROPRIATION
FUND A CREATIVE ECONOMIES
INCENTIVE PROGRAM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
WE'VE HAD WITH THE COMMITTEE.
AND I PLEDGE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO WORK OUT THE
FINANCIAL -- LOGISTICS AND
CHALLENGES OF THE PROGRAM --
WITH ME HERE TODAY IS PATTY THE
GENERAL SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
LOS ANGELES TOURISM AND
CONVENTION BOARD -- J. J. BURRIS --
WITH VISIT ANAHEIM AND ALSO.
TOM PHONE IN FROM THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY COUNSEL'S OFFICE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES WHEN THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
YES -- GOOD MORNING MAYOR MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- I'M PATTI MAKE
JANET -- WITH LOS ANGELES
TOURISM AND AM HERE AND WHAT ONE
OF THE PROUD CO SPONSORS ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUE -- FROM
ANAHEIM AND OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN DIEGO --
WE BELIEVE THAT WE NEED A
CREATIVE ECONOMY INCENTIVE FUND --
TO ASSIST LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN
JURISDICTIONS -- IN THEIR
ABILITY TO COMPETE -- WITH
MUNICIPALITIES IN OTHER STATES
FOR ME -- THE A MAJOR EVENTS --
IS CITIES AND STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAVE BEGUN TO REALIZE
THE SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
BENEFITS OF THE MAJOR EVENTS
BRING THE COMPETITION HAS GOTTEN
EXTREMELY -- STAFF -- CALIFORNIA
IS THE MOST DIVERSE STATE IN THE
AMERICA.
ON THE STRENGTH OF OUR DIVERSITY
AND ARE INVOLVING INFRASTRUCTURE
HAVE -- POSITION CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES TO REALLY COMPETE
AND TO ATTRACT A WIDE VARIETY OF%
THE FENCE EVENTS IT COULD BE
FROM ARTS AND CULTURE FROM
SPORTS FROM ENTERTAINMENT FROM
AGRICULTURAL BUT EVENTS.
THAT ARE -- SPECIFIC OR COULD BE
UNIQUE TO A CITY COUNTY REGION
WITH IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW FROM
STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN DONE ONE
RECENTLY FROM MIKE ON ALL MAKES.
THAT MAJOR EVENTS DELIVER
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC BENEFIT AND
ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO JOB GROWTH
FOR THE HOSTING REGION WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SPILLOVER
AFFECTS -- BECAUSE OF LEISURE
VISITORS WHEN THEY COME TO A
DESTINATION FOR EVENT THEY TEND
IT MOST FREQUENTLY WILL TRAVEL
TO OTHER DESTINATIONS WITH AND
CALIFORNIA -- YOU CAN SEE FROM
THE VERY DIVERSE LIST OF SUPPORT
LETTERS I THINK THEY'RE OVER
SIXTY THERE -- THEY REPRESENT
DESTINATIONS VENUES BUSINESS
ORGANIZATIONS ARTS AND CULTURE
ORGANIZATIONS FROM UP AND DOWN
THE STATE BOTH FROM LARGER
COMMUNITIES AS WELL SMALLER
COMMUNITIES BOTH FOR MERLE AND
FROM URBAN COMMUNITIES AS WELL
SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE HI.
ON THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY WAS
CHAMBER US.
REPRESENT AN ORGANIZATION CALLED
VISIT ANAHEIM AND THANK YOU BEEN
WERE ALSO ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS.
OF SB SEVEN THIRTY SIX THIS TYPE
OF FUND IS NOT NEW INFACT IS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED IS BEING USED
USED IN SEVERAL DIFFERENT STATES.
AND SEVERAL DIFFERENT CITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN ORDER TO
ATTRACT MAJOR EVENTS -- TO THEIR
DESTINATIONS I HAVE FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE HAVING -- LIVED IN
ONE OF THESE STATES IN THE TEXT
TEXAS IS BROUGHT OVER THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY EVENTS OVER A TEN
YEAR PERIOD TO THAT STATE --
COMPETING WITH OTHER STATES FOR
THOSE EVENTS THIS INCENTIVE FUND --
WILL ASSIST CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES TO ATTRACT THE VENTS
FROM ARTS AND CULTURAL TO
CULINARY SPORTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT TAG OF CULTURAL
EVENTS.
I HAVE A PERSONAL USED THE THE
FUND IN THE PAST TO ATTRACT THE
AMERICAN CUTTING HORSE
CHAMPIONSHIPS AS WELL AS A
SUPERBOWL AS WELL AS THE ACADEMY
OF COUNTRY MUSIC AWARDS WHICH
CAME TO TEXAS.
MANY YEARS AGO.
IN ADDITION TO DIRECT ECONOMIC
GAINS FOR COMMUNITIES THESE TYPE
OF EVENTS ALSO FOSTER INNOVATION
AND ENCOURAGE SPILLOVER EFFECTS
THAT CREATE JOBS.
AS WELL AS OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OTHER INDUSTRIES AND IMPORTANTLY
CAN BRING SOCIAL AND EDUCATIONAL
BENEFITS TO COMMUNITIES WITHIN
CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF THESE EVENTS TO BRING
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AT THE
INTRODUCED WITH THROUGHOUT THE
SCHOOLS AND THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITY ACCEPTS SO IT'S A WIN
WIN FOR BOTH.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS
BILL IN A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY.
NO.
GOOD MORNING I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS I
ASSISTED IN THE DRAFTING OF THE
BILL.
LET ME GO AHEAD AND CONTINUE
WITH -- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
TODAY'S.
FATE CALMLY WITH LA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
NOTHING GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF
ENTERPRISE RENTAL CARS PER.
GREG HAZEM HAVE WARNER BROTHERS
IN SPORTS.
JOYCE ON BEHALF OF ENDEAVOR ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ROBERT MITCHUM TO
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE NOW I I DO WANT TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE AUTHOR AND
ASKED WILL YOU BE ACCEPTING
TODAY'S -- PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WONDERFUL WONDERFUL
THANK YOU -- I DO WITH THAT.
I DO WANT TO I JUST SAY THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH -- OUR
STAFF -- ON THIS BILL I KNOW
THAT WE WORKED ON A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS THAT OVER THE COURSE
OF YESTERDAY AND I WILL SAY.
I AM PREPARED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL I DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE DO MOTION I AND FEEL
FREE ARE FOR THOSE A TESTIFIED
IN SUPPORT TO ANSWER AS WELL.
I NOTICED THAT WITHIN THE BILL
LANGUAGE THERE'S NO WILL
PRIORITIES PRIORITIES IDENTIFIED
WHEN IT COMES TO RATING OR
RANKING -- CRITERIA FOR THE
REVIEW OF ANY APPLICATIONS WHAT
ARE YOU ENVISIONING AS A
PROGRAMS PRIORITIES -- AND
EVALUATION CRITERIA.
OF THE THE MAIN THING IS THAT
NEEDS TO BE A NEW EVENT --
THAT'S COMING OR IT NEEDS TO BE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE --
SIGNIFICANT AKRON INCREMENTAL
VALUE SO EVEN IF IT IS A AN
EVENT THAT IS PERHAPS BàN.
IN A SMALLER CITY COULD BE
GILROY.
GARLIC VESSEL JUST USING AS AN
EXAMPLE IF THEY WANT TO INCREASE
IT SO THAT IT IS GOING TO BE
AGAIN GENERATE SIGNIFICANT --
TRUCK NEW BUSINESS FROM OUT OF
STATE INTO STATE -- THAT WOULD
HELP QUALIFY IT IT CERTAINLY CAN
BE A MAJOR EVENT THAT IS GOT
PROVEN ECONOMIC IMPACT THERE
WILL NEED TO BE A STUDY DONE
AHEAD OF TIME OR PROJECTION OF
FORECAST.
OF WHAT THAT ECONOMIC BENEFIT
WOULD BE AND THEN AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THE EVENT
OBVIOUSLY THERE WOULD BE A POST --
SERVICE THIS STUDY DONE AS WELL.
THANK YOU AND ARE JUST AN
ADDITIONAL QUESTION HOW DO YOU
SEE THIS PROGRAM ONLY SKILLED
FOR A LARGE EVENTS -- SUCH AS
THE NC DOUBLE A CHAMPIONSHIP OR
DO YOU SEE A FOR SMALLER
COMMUNITIES WHERE YOU'RE ABLE TO
HAVE A REGIONAL EVENT -- SUCH AS
A FALL HARVEST FESTIVAL HOW WHAT
WHAT WHAT IS THAT LOOK LIKE SO
MY VISION IS THAT THIS WOULD
BENEFIT OF ALL COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IN PARTICULAR
SMALLER COMMUNITIES SO --
CALIFORNIA IS A LOT OF NATURAL
ADVANTAGES WHEN WE'RE COMPETING
FOR THINGS LIKE CONVENTIONS OR
EVEN CULTURAL EVENTS LIKE
SHAKESPEARE FESTIVAL.
BUT IF THE COMMUNITY FOR EXAMPLE
HERE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WANTED TO COMPETE WITH THE STATE
OF OREGON FOR THE SHAKESPEARE
FESTIVAL WHICH WOULD BE A NEW
ENTERPRISE -- IN A SMALLER
COMMUNITY COULD HAVE BEEN A
GREATER.
IMPACT AT LEAST --
PROPORTIONATELY TO SMALLER
COMMUNITIES SO MY VISION IS THAT
THIS WOULD BE PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT FOR SMALLER
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR THIS MEASURE I HAPPEN TO
REPRESENT A COUPLE OF
COMMUNITIES ONE THAT HAS MOVED
FROM WHAT WOULD WOULD HAVE BEEN
CONSIDERED A SMALL COMMUNITY TO
A NICE MID SIZE CITY NOW.
AND IT WAS EXACTLY BECAUSE OF
OPPORTUNITIES -- LIKE THIS FOR
INSTANCE THEY HOST ANNUALLY A
LEG OF THE ENGINE TO WORK -- AND
IT HAS BROUGHT A LOT OF ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY TO THE REGION AS WELL
AS KIND OF YOU KNOW RAISE THE
PROFILE ON THE MAP.
BUT IF YOU THE COMMUNITIES I
REPRESENT STILL ARE THOSE SMALL
SIZED TOWNS AND THEY'RE LOOKING
TO HOST THINGS THAT RAISE THEIR
PROFILE AS WELL BRING SOME
RENEWED CULTURAL OR SPORTS
ACTIVITYTO THE COMMUNITY AND SO
I THINK THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
IDEA REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
AND MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU THAT THAT IS EXACTLY
THE KIND OF EVENT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE A BICYCLE
RACE FOR EXAMPLE CAN BE HELD
VIRTUALLY ANY PLACE IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND SO IF IF WE COMPETE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE ATTRACT THAT
BICYCLE RACE HAVE BEEN NEWS AND
THEN IT IT'S GOING -- TO
INCREASE THE ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
IN AND WHATEVER COMMUNITY
WHEREVER IT'S LOCATED IN IT'S
IT'S GOING.
TO PUT THAT COMMUNITY ON THE MAP
IN SOME RESPECTS AS WELL.
I MUST SAY I KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN SOME CONVERSATION WITH --
GO BIZ AND DIE I WANTED JUST TO
ASK YOU WILL.
THERE BE MORE THAN ONE
APPLICATION BE CONSIDERED FOR
THE SAME EVENTS ARE IF SO HOW
WOULD GO OF IT GOBIZ EVALUATES --
THE APPLICATION TO CHOOSE A
WINNER COULD THERE BE.
JUST.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S MAYBE A
RESPONSE TO THAT OR NOT YEAH IS
IT AN ONGOING CONVERSATION YOU
HAVE WITH GO BIZ AT THIS.
POINT IN TIME -- ALAN JO JUMP IN
BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
WILL IT THE THE THAT WILL
ALREADY NEED TO BE AWARDED --
PRIOR TO THE THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE.
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION ABOUT TO DEVELOP
WHAT THE CRITERIA ARE TO DEAL
WITH.
COMPETITIVE ARE COMPETING --
APPLICANTS FOR THE SAME OFFENSE
I MEAN IDEALLY -- YOU KNOW THE
STATE WOULD GET BEHIND ONE
APPLICANTS SO IT WOULD HAVE TO
EVALUATE THOSE COMPETING
APPLICATIONS. TO START.
I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO MY OWN
VISION MY OWN VISION WOULD BE IF
FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF THE LARGEST
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA WERE
COMPETING FOR THE SAME EVENT
WITH. FOR EXAMPLE A SMALLER
LOCATION IT WOULD BE MY PERSONAL
POINT OF VIEW -- THIS IS NOT THE
WORK OUT MY PERSONAL POINT OF
VIEW IS THAT THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
THE PROPORTIONATE ECONOMIC
IMPACT IN THE SMALLER COMMUNITY.
MEANS THE THAT THE STATE HAS A
GREATER INTEREST IN LOCATING
THAT OF AND THE SMALLER
COMMUNITY.
WONDERFUL WHAT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL -- FOR IT I
THINK THE THURS SAT MANY THINGS
THAT I LOVE TO SEE -- YOU DON'T
SEE THIS COME TO FRUITION AS I
KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WORKING TOGETHER AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THOSE WHO CAME IN
AND TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT FOR
TODAY'S MEASURE -- WITHOUT I
WILL.
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL -- DO WE
HAVE ANY OBJECTIONS TO ADOPTING
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
SCENE -- NINE THIS BILL IS DUE
PROCESS BE SEVEN THREE SIX IS
DUE PASSED THE MOMENTS TO
PREPARATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WE HAVE.
A MOTION.
BY SIMPLY MEMBER SMITH IN THE
SECOND BY VICE CHAIR CUNNINGHAM.
ITEM FIVE SB SEVEN THIRTY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH THE
MEMBERS TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR CERVANTES.
CHAU CERVANTES ANA PLACER
CUNNINGHAM.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM AYE CHANNEL.
CHANNEL ON A CHEN.
CHEN I RAMOS.
RAMOS I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE SMITH.
SMITH HI.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
WHAT DOT SO I CONCLUDES TODAY'S
HEARING I THANK YOU FOR ALL
THOSE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
THIS IS NOW ADJOURNED